a big investment initially solar panels
designed to save you money over time but
just how well do they withstand the wind
we see here in the valley well mary jane
belliesa shares how you should protect
your solar panels
with strong gusty winds in the valley
over the past few days luis helton owner
of one sun solar electric says winds can
cause more property destruction than you
think we get those micro cells that just
come from out of nowhere and it can
really stir up a huge more than brisk a
bold wind that can really do some damage
to a lot of things and solar panels are
things you need to be careful of helton
says while solar panels are designed to
withstand damaging winds it all comes
down to the condition of your roof and
installation quality and you place this
where you need to be so you're putting
your your clamps every four feet and
then it goes into the truss with a
couple of these very huge lag bolts les
lazarek is a member of solar nevada the
local chapter of the american solar
energy society he says while its
possible winds may lift and blow away
solar mass they're at the mercy of the
sun their life is
more limited by just
the heat
that it just their life they're not
warranteed like 25 years like most
panels are probably going to have a 5-10
year life lazaric and helton say routine
maintenance is key as well as keeping an
eye on your power bills and your roof we
recommend you check once a year to make
sure the connections are all solid and
that everything is good you know it's a
service we provide as more and more are
installed
the odds of finding anomalies or
installation issues
will come to the surface more mary jane
baleza live local now